President Trump called the Texas gunmen
deranged and said the shooting is a
mental health problem at the highest
level made the comment overnight at a
joint news conference in Tokyo with the
Prime Minister of Japan the president is
wrapping up the Japanese part of a five
nation trip through Asia you'll be in
Seoul South Korea tomorrow before going
to Beijing China major carry major
Garrett is traveling with the president
he's in Tokyo good morning good morning
confronted with a second mass shooting
of his presidency this time while
traveling in a country where gun
violence is virtually non-existent
president Trump offered prayers and
condolences and just as he did after the
Las Vegas Massacre said in these early
grief filled hours it is simply too soon
to talk about gun control this isn't a
guns situation I mean we could go into
it but it's a little bit soon to go into
it standing with Japanese Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a the president cast the
Texas Massacre strictly as a matter of
mental illness this is a mental health
problem at the highest level in his
first remarks on the shooting mr. Trump
called it an act of evil but did not as
he did soon after the terrorist attack
in New York described the assailant as
an animal the victims and their families
were in their place of sacred worship we
cannot put into words the pain and grief
we all feel but the president came to
Japan to begin a region-wide push to
intensify economic and diplomatic
pressure on North Korea repeating his
determination to force Pyongyang to
relinquish its nuclear weapons and
ballistic missiles that US intelligence
fears could soon reach the US mainland
the era of strategic patience is over
some people said that my rhetoric is
very strong but look what's happened
with very weak rhetoric over the last 25
years a bay has pledged to increase
military spending to prevent more
ballistic missiles launched over his
country by North Korea mr. Trump said
the US could help the Prime Minister
with that problem he will shoot him out
of the sky when he completes the
purchase of lots of
you know military equipment from the
United States during his two days here
the president said repeatedly Japan was
inclined to purchase a wide variety of
US weaponry for the most part the Prime
Minister remained quiet during these
declarations but in the end said Japan
is inclined to purchase more f-35s and
anti-missile ships for its Navy
specifics remain elusive and may fall
well short of the president's lofty
expectations Norah all right major
Garrett in Tokyo thank you